I am Daisy Anwar from metro TV and I
chaired the infrastructure possession
and Mark ravaged past he would honor my
client consultation or chairman of the
investment coordination I think it's a
very very timely session little
treasures have to be enough in Jakarta
Jakarta is one of the most congested
cities in the world and infrastructure
is one of the biggest problems of
individual spaces may answer in any one
renewed build the last ten years always
power blackout and of course being a
growing and developing economy is not
important that infrastructure was should
also match the economic growth and the
session discusses what were actually on
the challenges of our challenge
expensive infrastructure development and
communication that it's particularly
Indonesia what first thing ends promise
me financing organism and its awesome
liquidity that the in terms of them
actually utilizing the plans that's one
big issue the other one is not an
accusation once the bottlenecks that
Indonesia has basically console million
structure which is basically requiring
the RAB ka talab however internal
purposes that there is why it is in some
of the moving of regulation that would
make land acquisitions long sessions
lasting proposed regulations and the
process is something that is constantly
learn charity party questions lots had
takes lots of bureaucracies tests that
are not transparencies are issues that
the government of Indonesia is resolved
in order to make infrastructure and
attractive investment for
as well as well as to make sure that
infrastructure does not stay as a little
prince the plan is a project but
actually get in chemical stop that this
car will try to jab each other nicely
played